Українські політики активно дискутують
про необхідність своєрідних торгів із Кремлем -
відновлення водопостачання анексованого Криму
в обмін на виведення російських військових з окупованого Донбасу.
- Дати воду в Крим, але
мати велике...
велику якусь перевагу...
в перемовинах по Донбасу?
Моя особиста позиція - що я буду
вважати це достатнім компромісом.
Таким чином і прихильники, і противники цієї ідеї,
вочевидь, виходять із того, що Крим конче потребує
відновлення постачання води з материкової України.
Та чи справді Крим не може прожити без дніпровської води?
Аби знайти відповідь на це запитання, необхідно
повернутися в часи до анексії Криму Росією 2014 року.
Північно-Кримським каналом, що з'єднує головне русло Дніпра
з півостровом, надходило до 85%  необхідної
для Криму води. Загалом на рік півострів
із характерним для нього посушливим літом
потребував до півтора мільярда кубометрів прісної води.
Це сумарний річний обсяг води з Північно-Кримського каналу
і місцевої кримської води. Такі дані Кримської Академії наук.
700 мільйонів кубометрів йшло на вирощування рису,
ще 200 мільйонів - на поля рапсу, сої, пшениці
й кормових культур для тваринництва.
Загалом на потреби сільського господарства
витрачали щонайменше 70% води
з Північно-Кримського каналу. Лише 10% води з Дніпра
використовували як питну. Некритичні перебої
з водою були і до анексії Криму. Переважно це було
пов’язано ще з радянською зношеною інфраструктурою постачання води,
однак справжні проблеми з водою почалися,
коли у відповідь на анексію Криму Росією Київ
у 2014 році перекрив  Північно-Кримський канал.
Загальне споживання води в Криму впало у 5 разів:
до 300 млн кубометрів на рік.
Після припинення водопостачання кримська земля,
як засвідчують місцеві жителі, почала знову
засолюватися, стаючи непридатною для землеробства.
Зникають цілі галузі сільського господарства,
такі як вирощування рису, сої, кормових культур.
Зрошення кримських полів за роки окупації
скоротилося зі ста сорока до лише десяти тисяч гектарів.
Запасів прісної води у кримських водосховищах
вистачить до червня 2020 року,
запевняє на Фейсбуці керівник Держкомводгоспу Криму Ігор Вайль.
За його словами, населення  забезпечується водою
з 22 водосховищ і з підземних джерел.
Водосховища природного стоку станом на початок лютого
заповнені на 32-34%, заспокоює Вайль.
Щоправда, наповнення цих водосховищ залежить передусім від погодних умов.
Додатково самопроголошена влада Криму
виділяє гроші на буріння артезіанських свердловин.
Доводиться бурити глибше 100 метрів, аби воду
можна було пити. Також з'являються
сотні нелегальних свердловин. Однак чим більше
свердловин, тим гіршою є якість питної води, адже
з нижніх горизонтів піднімається солона вода.
Глава окупаційної влади Криму Сергій Аксьонов
стверджує, що якісну питну воду отримують 77% населення,
і очікує від Москви щонайменше 300 млн доларів
на реконструкцію Міжгірського водосховища.
Водночас самопроголошена влада регулярно
закликає мешканців півострова економити воду.
Окупаційна влада не афішує нестачу води
в сільському господарстві, проте ініціює
переорієнтацію підприємств на вирощування культур,
які не потребують значного зрошування.
Наразі Крим може прожити без дніпровської води
й насправді робить це вже майже шість років.
Утім, ідеться при цьому лише про потреби
в питній воді кримського населення.
Засолення ґрунтів і поява солоної води
в артезіанських свердловинах свідчать про те, що
почалися природні процеси, на подолання яких
можуть піти десятиріччя. Аби повернутися
до доокупаційного рівня розвитку сільського господарства,
Криму не обійтися без безперервного постачання
значних обсягів води з Дніпра.